[Musique]
barre des Fils
vengeance vengeance
[Musique]
C'est ici
Je les ai appelés de toutes les manières possibles
les ravisseurs m'ont traité de criminels
J'ai utilisé des termes
quelles que soient les conditions qu'ils ont acceptées
les épithètes que j'ai calmement données
et simplement quand j'ai dit mon Dieu
c'est la seule expression que j'ai
il a vu pourquoi je ne suis jamais parti
va mais plusieurs fois Voici, j'ai dit Dieu
mon mon Dieu À ce stade, ils sont ici oui
ils se sont rebellés contre le Seigneur, ne dis pas mon Dieu
Dieu appartient à tout le monde
Dieu est à nous et moi et moi avons répondu qu'il ne pouvait pas
être
à toi en ce moment est le Seigneur Dieu
dans sa grande bonté, ce sera peut-être toi
je pardonnerai quand je demanderai pardon
de l'acte que vous faites mais en cela
moment où Dieu ne peut pas être à vos côtés
partie ici mais ils se sont rebellés quand
Je les ai exclus
de ce que je pourrais être la communauté
religieux catholique
quand ils m'ont apporté de la nourriture et j'ai vu
un ordre dans les choses qu'il m'a fait
pense à penser sans jamais rien d'autre
personne n'a jamais parlé de femmes et seulement
un ici
Je t'ai rappelé quelqu'un qui se souvenait de beaucoup de choses
mère, je pense que les femmes savent
en tout cas, c'est comme ça que les femmes le justifient
les enfants la non-présence
comment les mères justifient leurs femmes
Je sais parfaitement quand mon mari part
loin et pourquoi ça s'en va
Comment ces mères ou ces épouses
ne réalisant pas que le mari
il est sans aucun doute occupé avec quelque chose et
alors je demanderais
c'est une complicité
c'est l'histoire
[Musique]
Bonjour Bonjour, bonsoir
Bonsoir bonsoir
Cher Ciccio
un conseil Elle me l'a dit tu as demandé
faim sur la protection des sondes
aussi boghetta devant
ni Contre qui contre
enfants
la Fanta Pasubio
protection
Soyons réalistes, c'était une personne ordinaire
comme tous les autres ce n'était rien
surtout moi avec mes yeux
Cependant, je l'ai vu comme très particulier
c'était un homme très normal, c'était très
courtisé ça Oui, il en avait beaucoup
les femmes qui marchent autour de nous aussi
parce que la question quand il s'agit de
un mafieux
Disons que nous parlons comme si nous le faisions
je parlais d'un acteur d'une actrice
Disons que je ne suis pas ça, c'est-à-dire que ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas comme si c'était lui qui m'avait eu
j'ai dit que je le suis
C'est moi qui le savais à part
quand ma mère me l'a dit et puis
bref, je pense que je n'ai pas tout à fait raison
Je suis tellement stupide que je ne peux pas
comprends même si j'étais un garçon que je ne pourrais pas
comprendre qu'il avait une vie
tout sauf normal, bref, pas comme
Mais tous les autres sont des trafiquants
mais qu'a-t-il fait
J'ai reçu quelque chose et ce n'est pas qu'il ne l'a pas fait
et il n'a pas
nous en sommes aux premiers jours surtout jamais
j'ai mentionné ce que j'avais compris
J'ai compris, c'est-à-dire j'ai compris pourquoi j'ai vu
J'ai vu des mouvements étranges
des gens avec des visages étranges et j'ai vu
le respect qui a été témoigné à son peuple
comparer la façon de se comporter Et entre
toutes les autres choses
Parlons du comportement des gens
qui est venu vers moi qui
avec, en bref, une pincée
Que puis-je te dire? Disons quelque chose
un peu de fierté Alors je
Je me sentais comme un protagoniste. Bref, je me sentais comme
j'ai aimé j'ai aimé j'ai senti que j'ai aimé
J'ai senti quelqu'un, peut-être que je me suis senti moi-même
quelqu'un que je n'étais pas en fait alors non
J'étais ici, j'en étais content aussi
ils embrassent ces gens qui sont venus vers moi
ils avaient beaucoup de respect Oui
ils m'ont adressé la parole avec beaucoup de politesse
faim avec des noms de famille
Toto victime Toto cumpleas
[Musique]
On m'a demandé cela plus d'une fois
il demande si les femmes ont réagi
dénonçant leurs fils, maris, frères
ce phénomène mafieux pourrait arriver
d'une manière ou d'une autre
frappe et mais apprends-moi quelqu'un ou
quelqu'un qui est possible que
les épouses, les mères, les sœurs rapportent leur
Cher
si l'association devait être frappée de
dentiste mafieux à travers, disons, le
le choix des femmes c'est une naissance
certainement imaginatif, mais cela ne peut pas
répondre à la réalité parce que chaque mère
même s'il a un fils délinquant, il essaie
pour le protéger, tout comme sa femme et
la sœur aussi et ainsi de suite
pour qu'ils ne choisissent pas de s'opposer au
mafia
ils choisissent de se tailler cet espace pour eux-mêmes
le matriarcat pour pouvoir vivre je peux
Je ne les comprends même pas, mais je peux
comprends-les aussi
parce que sinon ce serait impossible
vivre dans un pays violent parce qu'il existe
violence contre une femme qui vient
de l'État une violence qui vient de
famille une violence qui vient de
société une violence qui vient de
organisations criminelles et mafieuses quoi
cette femme devrait faire
Il y avait une telle haine en moi
si féroce que je m'en souviens un jour
après En bref Non après après une semaine
à propos de ça
parce que je suis sorti
Parce que ce n'est que vers la fin que je suis
J'ai trouvé tellement de monde à ce moment-là
auquel je devais aussi m'occuper
les funérailles pour les choses, c'était moi
avec ma sœur alors de
par conséquent j'ai dû sortir et faire
tout ça ici
et je me souviens que tu m'as rencontré un
garçon et m'a empêché de les faire
condoléances Alors depuis que je savais
avec qui ce garçon sortait. Soyons réalistes
la La famille d'une personne qui avait
avait quelque chose à voir avec ce meurtre E
alors il me fait si Giacomina je le fais
mes condoléances et je lui ai dit : écoute
Je sais que tu sors avec cette personne
tu dois dire dit sel je ne dois pas l'être
tellement en colère que ça puisse arriver
tu as dit Ecoute, c'est la seule chose
qu'ils ont commis une erreur. C'était effectivement
Je leur ai dit qu'ils n'en avaient pas
ils m'ont tué, ils ne m'ont pas tué
avec lui et ensuite je ferai tout
tu peux aller lui dire que je vais le faire
tout ça si je le rencontre ou du moins
quand ce sera sorti si je peux
sa propre force, je briserai la sienne
poitrine, je mangerai son cœur, la seule chose
la colère que je l'avais dit
Disons que je suis empoisonné si je l'avais
trouvé devant moi à ce moment-là
Je l'aurais fait sans y réfléchir à deux fois et
Bref, c'est tout ce qu'il me reste
à l'intérieur de cette chose puis lentement
avec ces gens je répète que je
bref, ils venaient toujours chez moi
ils m'ont donné un peu de consolation
il a envoyé chercher le médecin
Borsellino et moi y sommes allés et ainsi
Bref, une certaine certitude a commencé
conversation avec lui et
quand je me suis retrouvé, disons assis là
moi derrière lui derrière le bureau moi
derrière la chaise, faisons face
il a trouvé une personne Disons que je
Je ne le voyais pas comme un magistrat Mais comment
un ami à qui s'exprimer et dire
mes affaires et je dis sincèrement
c'est-à-dire que je le voyais aussi comme une personne
qui m'a aidé à me venger
les femmes qui y vivent
il peut souvent s'agir de femmes de
agrandisseurs mais ils peuvent aussi être
les gens normaux, tout n'est pas mafieux
Reggio de Calabre, tout ne se passera pas bien
la culture du peuple en est une autre
lesquels préfèrent souvent vivre ensemble et
ne pas être et ne pas appartenir vivre ensemble
même si dans les communes de notre Monte Le
gens
ils se retrouvent souvent confrontés à
avec un membre de la famille qui, pour ma part
la raison est une autre jointure
de la famille ou parce qu'il se fiance ou
parce qu'il se marie donc il y a une présence
qui est étroitement lié dans ces municipalités
les gens qu'ils sont vraiment
de l'organisation et quelqu'un qui arrive
pour mille pour une raison qui n'est peut-être pas
c'est la 'ndrangheta mais ce sont les relations
les humains et la famille
et prisonnier
Non
[Musique]
Comme on dit, tout va bien
la fille les images de Jésus
écoute-les, Mère de Dieu Consolato e
puis Regina sans
tache
rossafila lys de pureté Bonjour étoile
tôt le matin
et puis un divorce mais c'est beau
fiancé
tous mes frères, tous les partis
soldats
un mariage quand j'aurai 46 ans
J'ai répondu
J'adore jeudi
1 de Pélide
veux tu venir
pendant
à Dieu
fils Pascalis à mon fils Pasquale
lentement lentement lentement ça m'excite
Dieu travaillant le sacrifice vous amène
vas-y et épouse-les tous les deux
il dit bien parce que c'est bien tellement bien
Marco était fermé
Ah, ce sont les vieux Super Marios
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
viens viens viens viens viens
viens
Viens viens
un petit salut mais fais attention à ne pas le faire
puis tombe
Oui oui, reste certainement
[Musique]
peut-être qu'il aura des amis mais ils le sont
ce n'est pas amusant oui mais il dit
calme
Ugh, ça se ferme autant que je le pense et donne
autant que je pensais que non
Je pensais que je m'en fichais
au moins, il pensait que ça n'avait aucun type
avec n'importe qui si tu ne donnes pas autant que tu as
mari mais il le voulait mais il l'appréciait
c'est exactement pour tout
Ce n'est pas ainsi que tu devrais prendre la vie
comment ça se fait parce que tout cela n'est pas de l'or
avec la lumière, il faut quand le faire
il y a celui qui souffre, c'est une maladie
et il y a ceux qui souffrent pour
mariage
nous avons notre propre destin, ce n'est pas Devi
peut-être voir ou le voisin veut
eh bien, ça lui va, peut-être que ce voisin de
la maison souffre plus que nous
de loin en général en général
Et je n'ai jamais pensé en tant que mari et
visage tu as ma mère parce que tout le monde
gâteau
vidéo de fumée, j'ai à moitié fini
Je ne dis juste pas de faveur
si tu sais déjà que cette vie et qu'elle vole
des hommes qui ne se sont pas perdus
la [ __ ] et celle qu'il voulait mêlées
mais je n'ai jamais apprécié YouTube
des passions
de nos inclinations au mal
l'ouragan des épreuves
de lui
de difficulté de toutes sortes
difficultés matérielles
difficultés spirituelles
et ces dangers
[Musique]
non seulement possible mais prévisible
inévitable
[Musique]
c'est-à-dire de sponsors dans l'état
les usines dictées en suprême n'étaient pas
ils prenaient du pantanetos depuis septembre
Fils de mémoire
[Musique]
les rites soignés
l'ouverture de la thèse Vierge signifie
l'expression de l'entreprise est venue
morsiville je nourris Spice sur la lune
de roses
ce sont des pâtes pour réfrigérateur non
re bourré
[Musique]
Je peux presque te voir là, l'homme goûte à chaque
émigration différente du jeu vidéo
casabottom est nécessaire en dessous
pars s'il te dit juste que je ne le suis pas
OK ici si tu as le temps Tom
et le village de Rotondo
[Musique]
à certains égards, l'homme calabrais moi
Je l'aime à certains égards
Mais pourquoi peut-être parce que têtu et alors
sous l'entêtement que ça te fait entrevoir il y a
je pense qu'il est sûr de ce qu'il veut
ça te fait penser que tu creuses au fond et pourtant
il est plein de peurs, de doutes et de
incertitudes
ou justement derrière un apparent
la sécurité se cache souvent
Je ne sais pas, je ne veux pas dire des choses dures
mais peut-être
peu de courage
Oui peut-être l'homme calabrais ainsi que
Madonna à mon avis à mon avis
et courageux à certains égards et à d'autres
Non
Je ne sais pas si je dois dire je ne sais pas s'il l'a choisi
ou un
choix forcé
peut-être forcé, je ne connais pas le sort
ce que je pense de la Vierge
ce qui est toujours un choix, une question de
choix qui est
c'est sans aucun doute une vertu car il y a
tu l'as peut-être pas
Il ne sait pas
Oui c'est un point fort Peut-être
c'est un point fort pour les femmes tu sais
parce que surtout quand tu arrive
un certain âge
parce qu'alors c'est devenu oh bien
concentrons-nous sur la force, le point fort
parce que si
Il faut aussi regarder ses priorités
c'est à dire, je ne sais pas. C'est aussi une question de
priorité à l'éducation, je veux dire
si on s'en soucie
et s'il s'agit d'une question de valeur dans laquelle
croit Et puis la virginité est importante
il est très important
parce que s'il devait le perdre et peut-être que
perd pour une question de je ne sais pas
Peut-être parce que tu t'es retrouvé à l'intérieur
situations dans lesquelles vous êtes parvenu à le perdre
Mais au fond tu y croyais.
tout devient plus difficile parce que ce n'est pas le cas
un choix que tu fais pour rester
vierge ou pas mais
en position plus que toute autre chose
Mais justement parce qu'il y a des valeurs qui
ils persistent encore ici que dans d'autres régions
Peut-être qu'ils étaient perdus dont nous parlions avant
la virginité est toujours ici dans le sud, peut-être
que les 100 000 filles se rencontrent
vert ce qui à la place n'est pas Ou dans
autres pays
ce n'est pas facile de se rencontrer
C'est une couverture plus puissante que vous allez
avec un chinois et fils de coton quand
on épouse la porte ouverte
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je pense de la mafia
c'est un problème un peu difficile parce que vous
je t'explique tout de suite
la mafia est vue
pour les raisons pour lesquelles il est né
Qui étaient pratiquement ce qu'on appelle
les hommes d'honneur qui l'ont
a commencé à se répandre comme mentalité
je ne suis pas vraiment contre
Pourquoi pourquoi
à mon avis
il faut alors faire attention pour voir ce que
Je ne suis pas contre, ils ne sont pas contre
discours de défense de
de protection même si cela te revient
je répète si on le compare
Je ne devrais même pas dire religion
quelque chose comme ça parce que
aucun homme ne peut s'ériger en défenseur
d'un autre
du moins en ce qui concerne la vie
c'est-à-dire décider de la vie.
l'aspect alors dégradé de la mafia ou
condamne celui du meurtre de la prise
initiatives en ce sens pour décider
éliminer quelqu'un parce qu'il lui fait une chapelle devant
parce que ça commence à déranger
Mais je suis contre ça si j'y pense
raison
du discours d'honneur, peut-être sont-ils
traditionaliste en ce sens
que mesdames, je mettrai fin à mes prisons
au sud du QR kinder”
[Musique]
la Madone de la jeunesse
Je suis avec iPad mais sur deux US
ils représentent
de l'eau cependant
J'ai dit à quel point tout cela avait duré
faim
le port de viasc en tant que Food people
et la Madone est Seigneur désolé
le silonce Fam Swift et la Madone de Bon
et maître du Loch
les souris sont la Madone de
père
[Musique]
tu es mon hôpital
aujourd'hui mon aventure est belle
[Musique]